Про всяк випадок в мене більше 50
поправок будь не врахованих Шановні
колеги чим ми сьогодні з вами займаємося
з одного боку нам говорять що ми тут
боремося за євроінтеграційний закон
насправді ми вичищаємо це
євроінтеграційний закон зараз від дуже
багатьох хотілок влади які насправді
євроінтеграція це взагалі не про
євроінтеграцію тому що цей закон мав на
меті імплементувати в українське
законодавство директиву про
аудіовізуальні медіапослуги що ми зараз
з вами голосували виборче законодавство
звичайно регулювання Про вибори має бути
у виборчому кодексі але воно було тут до
останнього дня хоча ми вже місяцями
говорили що так не повинно бути і нам
казали дададами почуємо чим ми тут
займалися ми виписували в останній день
вдумайтесь поправку по каналу рада
насправді по цьому каналу ми розмовляли
декілька місяців вже купа з посів було
зламано тому що насправді це не реформа
це антиреформа це проведення назад в
законодавству України державного
телеканалу Ми з 14-го року зробили все
щоб провести роздержавлення А зараз ми
приходимо до абсолютно не європейської
практики і на додачу до каналу Freedom
на додачу до суспільно-мовника на який
витрачається більше двох мільярдів разом
на загальний марафон ми ще беремо канал
Рада із парламентського каналу створюємо
з нього загальнонаціональний канал який
парламент не показує взагалі
не показує Він показує офіс президента
хрень всяку що завгодно тільки не
засідання парламенту Мені здається що це
якось ненормально парламенту за це
голосувати правда ну це так от саме
обрізанням займатися просто публічно не
більше і не менше далі що тут ще є
схотела от що тут залишилося це
регулювання онлайн
взагалі-то Коли ми говоримо про
європейські принципи то європейські
принципи - це про свободу слова правда
ну ми хочемо все зарегулювати в нас
взагалі-то не регулюється інтернет Але
російських сайтів не бачите страна.ua
заблокований санкційні інструменти
дозволяють все це робити але ні ми
вирішили що ми ще будемо регулювати
інтернет причому регулювати достатньо
жорстко колеги щоб ви розуміли якщо в
когось з вас є якісь дружній
інтернет-сайти То тепер щоб їх не
закрила нацрада вони змушені будуть
зареєструватися як засоби масової
інформації але це не означає що на них
не будуть тиснути тому що нацрада зможе
до кожного сайту прийти з перевіркою
попросити бухгалтерські документи
зокрема а от сайти які так звано будуть
віднесені до категорії анонімних або
незареєстрованих можуть бути просто
просто заблоковані ви думаєте від нас
європейці цього вимагають Ні це
абсолютно внутрішня вимога тому що
вибачте але спочатку війни ми зачистили
інформаційний простір України на
телебаченні і радіо там показують одне
єдиний великий марафон в тому Марафоні
ви знаєте мені не прикро що там немає
представників парламенту хрен з нами тут
всіма там солдатів насправді практично
немає там правди немає розумієте там є
тільки Герої пропагандисти які тепер Всі
в сотні видатних українців завдяки цьому
єдиному марафону херня тут сидить яка
оце верещить
замість того
щоб Це ваші Я вас цитувала так от для
того щоб мало телевізійного виявляється
простору цей марафон впав в рейтингу в
два рази і більше люди вже просто його
не дивляться лишається єдиний
інформаційний простір
Це інтернет Що треба зробити з
інтернетом
зарегулювати інтернет і тому оцей закон
має на меті зачистити ще
інтернет-простір це погана історія і
Повірте запихувати його в
євроінтеграційний ну це такий верх
цинізму по-своєму але будемо стежити за
імплементацією цього всього Я вже не
кажу про те що Знаєте в Україні
погані закони компенсовуються їх
невиконанням будемо сподіватися що і тут
виконуватися всі ті норми стиску і пресу
які закладаються Вони просто-напросто не
будуть ми в принципі спостерігаємо за
тим що закони які гарантують свободи
слова не виконуються ви знаєте що
відключено три патріотичні національні
телеканали до них не було претензій у
сфері безпеки їх просто вимкнули з
цифрового мовлення Як це називається
дуже просто цензура чи
європейським стандартам Ні не відповідає
але зараз ми говоримо дуже багато гарних
слів про
євроінтеграцію Я просто хочу вам
нагадати Це не про Україну Україна не
сприймала цензуру ніколи від часів Кучми
і не сприйме далі тим хто сподівається
зачистити Все я вам нагадаю чим це
закінчується революціями хлопці які
зараз на фронті Вони борються там за
демократію а не за те щоб ми тут з вами
перетворювали Україну на Росію і
Білорусь дякую